mark Rylance is just awesome can we all
just address that right now the mark
Rylance is just the man all right cool
the BFG so the BFG is adapted from
children's novel that i remember when i
was in first grade i was looking forward
to this matter
I heard Spielberg was doing it I was
excited to hurt mark Rylands was gonna
be the BFG I was like I want to see this
movie today
basically there's a little orphan girl
her name's Sophie she's very lonely and
the BFG the Big Friendly Giant that's
what BFG stands for what else would have
stand for Tomb fans you tell me what
would it stand for The BFG see Sophie he
grabs her he snatches her up and he
takes her to giant country and that's
where they have their adventure by
adventure I mean really it's a movie
about them bonding and being friends and
that's the thing about it if there's one
director out there who can take the
premise of a grown giant a grown man
befriending a little girl and make it
not creepy it's Steven Spielberg and
this really does harken back to his
early days of directing you know where
he made movies about friendship and
magic you know like jaws all right fine
et and it's a sweet movie but at a point
you start thinking about it you're like
to what end is all this happening and
really the end is them being friends
that's the point of the movie this movie
has the magic on wonder that comes from
a kid befriending someone from another
land and going to their land and seeing
their land it has its fair amount of
danger also as every other giant in
giant country eats children they call
them human beans beans because they are
their food and other than that premise
right they're like knowing that happens
in the world there's really nothing
gritty enough or dark enough to be like
oh that's actually going to scare
children and that it's a bit of a
squeaky-clean movie 2 squeaky-clean
movie about a little girl befriending a
giant and that that's what they do there
were a couple of times I was like what
can something happen I don't mean I
needed an action sequence or anything
like that I'm just saying I could have
gone for something like something to
really throw it in my face like oh whoa
turmoil like a giant picking his teeth
with someone's bones or something would
have been pretty awesome granted you
don't want to scare children I guess
that's the difference between me and
Spielberg I would have scared children
but the visual effects in this movie are
great there's so many times it was like
that looks like makeup on Mark Rylance
now getting to that moment we're CGI is
some
time's under the right conditions with
the right director looks more realistic
than makeup does it's actually a pretty
sweet top what a time to be alive and as
I said in the intro this video I love
Mark Rylance I thought he was great he
just brings the BFG to life he's a sweet
runt comparatively to the other Giants I
mean he's huge but he's not as huge as
they are he has a speech impediment you
just feel for him he has a big heart and
you just love seeing that the little
girl was great too I mean mark Rylands
and her they really had to bring their
a-game because for the majority of the
movie they're the only two real
characters in it so they had to bring
their chemistry but really it's this
little girls acting ability to act
against green screen I don't know how
they filmed I want to see the making of
because the whole time I'm like it's
marked Rylands they're acting with her
or she's just staring at a big X on a
stick and they're like yeah that's the
bf G's face so you know stare at it and
act your best either way good job kid I
mean she did a great job in the movie
the movie is pretty squeaky-clean it's
an enjoyable movie it's a nice Steven
Spielberg magical movie for kids and
families and if I've been completely
honest I think it's just nice to see
that in this day and age I walked out of
this movie feeling the magic I enjoyed
it I will say The BFG is a really good
time no alcohol required for those
families out there who told their kids
no sorry you can't watch the purge
alright guys so the BFG have you seen it
what did you think about it what's your
favorite movie adaptation of the kids
book that you loved as a kid whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you